amber heard shuts down reports she was
recast in aquaman 2.
the worst is yet to come
in the aftermath of amber losing in
johnny depp's defamation trial reports
surfaced on tuesday that she would no
longer appear in the sequel but a
spokesperson for the actress tells et
quote the rumor mill continues as it has
from day one inaccurate insensitive and
slightly insane
et has reached out to dc and warner
brothers for comment
you were not replacing aquaman 2 were
you
they released me from my contract
and i fought to stay in it and they kept
me in it aquaman 2 was a recurring topic
throughout the trial
amber filmed scenes for the movie in
march and as part of her testimony in
may she claimed her character's presence
was dialed back
i
was given a script and then
given new versions of the script
um that
had taken away
scenes that the
that that had action in it that had that
depicted um my character
and and
another character they basically took a
bunch out of my role the next day amber
noted there's a chance her performance
will be left on screen i don't know if i
will even be in the final cut or how
much i will be it was difficult to stay
in the movie
and the following week president of dc
based film productions for warner
brothers walter hamada claimed that
amber's role actually wasn't reduced for
the sequel the size of the role of film
that she has was determined in the early
development of the script which would
have happened
in 2018 i would say
so and from there beyond normal
development
the role sort of
the character's involvement in the story
was sort of what it was from the
beginning
the executive also claims there were
indeed conversations about recasting
amber's part but he alleges they were
due to her and jason mamoa's lack of
on-screen chemistry
there were conversations about pitchfork
recasting at the end of the day i think
if you watch the movie they look like
they had great chemistry but i just know
that through the course of the
post-production that it took a lot of
effort to get there sometimes you don't
sometimes it's very easy you just put
the you know characters on the screen
together they work and sometimes it's
harder
for the first time following the trial
amber opens up to nbc news with a
passionate stance on her testimony do
you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony despite the
verdict ruling in johnny's favor ambra
says she doesn't blame the jury i don't
blame them i actually understand he's a
beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor
you